-The most followed person on YouTube is this guy who's a gamer, his name is Pewdiepie
-Pewdiepie, yeah
-And he is the worst.
(cough)
Why do people hate me? I am so nice. Why would he?
stab me in the back like this?  This hurts
More than any dagger... than any racial slur.
You know from one Caucasian to another, I am disappointed.
I feel like someone just took my lunch, even though it said it had my name on it. I feel disgusted.
I really thought me and Perez were bros, 'cause he always writes such wonderful articles about me. Such as...
"Pewdiepie is the worst"
I am the worst everyone. We've hit the top top
top 10 worst YouTuber number one coming up, Pewdiepie
He is literally the worst. Pewdiepie responds to n-word backlash by sharing fellow white Youtuber's own
Offensive po- Perez, as a fellow white Youtuber, I know you used to do Youtube as well.
I am a little disappointed that you'd- you, you... tag this as "disgusting". Icky Icky poo. Grow the fuck up.
Do us all a favor. You know you wish I lost all my subscribers and went away. I wish you trip on your shoelaces. [wow roasted]
Surely no one else could possibly make fun of me on a day like this, 'cause it's- my day is ruined at this point.
(BG) Pewdiepie's still attacking us
Ohh, no. NO.
No. BG Kumbi, he responded.
(BG) After all these years of fighting this war
This war against Pewdiepie and the Bro Army
-No
-Me, Dylan..
We already surrendered, we already gave Pewdiepie all our money.
God damn right they did. That was the deal. You would have to give me all of your money. *burps*
Pocket change for someone rich and famous like me, really. I mean you can have it back. I don't really care.
I just don't like you, BG Kumbi, I just don't like you.
(BG) Dylan was even forced to do a collaborative comedy video with Pewdiepie against his will.
That's true. I forced Dylan the hacker,
because I beat all of you. You thought your hate could rise above me? Fuck you for even thinking that, I am the strongest,
handsomest, the most attractivest
Best Youtuber. If you come against me,
I'm going to come at you at least 20 times harder
And I'm going to come swinging. You can't beat me because my roasts are harder than anyone. So BG Kumbi keep crying, okay?
What the fuck are you going to do about it?
(BG) Still making fun of us
Because I- and you know why I keep attacking you? Because I enjoy it.
I find pleasure in destroying
little haters scumbags like you.
That was your mom laughing at you from the other room. I could hear that
Still
Pathetic
I just want to say that Pewdiepie humiliated me
in his latest video
-BG -He roasted me on the world stage in front of millions of people.
-Felix - That's goddamn right I did. Millions!
How many people watch your video? Eight thousand? Pathetic!
Now, I'm just trying to form something of the life after all I got turned upside down
-today
-Yeah, what are you going to do about it?
Pewdiepie don't think I will forget this
You won't forget it because it's... I tattooed it in your brain
I went inside your brain. I fucked it and I tattoed myself right in there. I'm in your brain forever, son
That's right. You're my child, spoilers. I didn't want to say anything, but I made you
If you want this war between us to continue, so be
You know I won't lie. I've made a few videos on Pewdiepie [haha]
You made a few? You made a few, that's rich. Your whole channel is pretty much dedicated to me
It's fucking sad. Look how many, disgusting!
You know? I thought youtube was against cyber-bullying. This sort of stuff should not be tolerated
He's clearly trying to destroy me. I rise above the hate 'cause I'm strong
Just look at this video you did about me, put  a fucking shirt on
So as must as you know by now
I'm on a Youtube war with Pewdipie
This war has been going on for many centuries
Even though I have won, I'm not going to stop
This is in 2014
Anyway, my response to Pewdiepie is back off
Hey man, that's all you had to say?
That's all you literally have to say you you decide to stay back off, and I'll back off. I swear to you
I do not like you in that way, okay?
-What are you...?
-You're not even hot guy
How f... How dare you? How? Pause this video
How dare you? Say that I don't have a haircut and a big six-pack
Fuck you
You don't even have a 3-pack. That's right
In the spring of my youth and a great meadow(I think)
Go out with someone your own age
You don't know, you don't know what I'm interested in, ok? You don't know if I like you or not. He can't just say that
You can't just say that I like you that doesn't make it true
Don't listen. He's trying to manip... this man is a manipulator. Do not listen to him. He's telling lies
Alright, also, I found that Pewdiepie's girlfriend has a crush on my friend Dylan
No, no, no, no, no
NO
You... Does he hacked her mind?
'Cause he hacked
She actually makes Pewdiepie dress up as Dylan the hacker and 3-pac(the rapper), otherwise, she can't make love to him
Noo!
This man it's feeding you lies, this man is practically the media. Watch out!
Yeah, Pewdiepie's a pervert and uh he's needs to be normal and date men his own age
What? I can date whoever men I want. Fuck you
For even saying that and no, I do not dressed up like Dylan the hacker and 3-pac to make love with Marzia
Okay? I don't have to do it. This war has only...
Begun
*song* IAMTHE-
Let's see what else he has to say in this stupid video
Hashtag resist Pewdiepie
-Tweet it if you want to support.
-You can hashtag all you want
You heard of hunger strikes? I'm going to go on a hunger binge
I'm taking it one step further
I'm going to eat snacks until Pewdiepie apologizes
I'm going to eat
Until I grow into a giant sumo wrestler(is this a fetish?)
Well, BG Kombi, prepare to explode because I am never and I say never
Apologizing to your sorry ass
That can squash Pewdiepie like a bug just by sitting on him
I officially challenged Pewdiepie to a sumo wrestling contest
-Are you...
-One has to spend the night locked in a closet with a male sex offender
Okay, okay
Loser has to eat 1,000 mung beans
You just said what the loser had to do. What the fuck are you talking about?
Loser has to get scalped by a tomahawk by a real life Indian lord
That seems fair, that seems fair
I know a guy that can hook us up and do the scalping, although not to be mean or anything
But it looks like there's not much work needed to be done there
You're, you're balding is what I'm saying
Loser has to hook car batteries up to his nipples
Okay, all right
Is that how we're going to do this BG Kumbi? well, I got some *garbled* rules to set as well.
Well... Jesus. Loser has to get Starbucks for at least a week!
In fact, I challenge Pewdiepie
to who can take more electrical shocks contest
We both look ourselves up to a car battery and go volt for volt until one of us passes out
Felix -I accept your challenge
BG -Who's rested, dump an entire bowl of Cornflakes over their head.
No, no, no, I'm not doing that, I'm not. That's fucked up dude. What the fuck?
I'm not going to waste Cornflakes for some stupid shit, dude. Think with your head not with your... bread
I am prepared to accept that challenge
However, if you lose you have to watch Grown Ups 2 with me and loser
Has to delete their mixtape
I challenge you to a pee drinking contest
where we urinate in eachothers faces
Merged your DNA with me, Pewdiepie
What?
This is an open challenge, I want to merge with Pewdiepie. I want to become him
I want to share my consciousness with the man himself
Number one subscribed person on Youtube
Just like Sadako vs Kayako
Hello, everyone, BG Kombi here
How's it going bros? My name is Pewdiepie
Pewdiepie and I would finally achieve the highest level of YouTube together
YouTube will make us a special plaque for 1 billion subscribers made out of the bones of all the youtubers ground into a woodchipper
sacrificed in our honor
We will finally become
the Greatest YouTube star
to ever live
Thank you.
Well BG Kombi, I want you to know that that was
a bunch of
nonsense. you can't merge DNA. I've tried it before
it's impossible
It was bad enough with 3-pac *he pronounced it three-pack*. We can't do this anymore. If you're not joking
There may be one person
That knows how to do this
and his name is
We must contact him
We must we must find this man
His name...
Is...
Jackspedicey